so how many years were you in the
federal government 20 years
oh my gosh that's incredible holy cow
man and when when you've been in the
government that long don't you get all
these crazy sweet benefits packages and
everything else like uh why do I feel
like you're departing the government was
somehow an unusual decision and also how
the heck did you wind up on ABC's sitcom
during this time where I know you're a
psych after member and the rest of it
well when I started working for the
government I remember meeting the
old-timers and they were on a different
retirement system it was called csrs and
I was on First and essentially at some
point in time the government decided
that the retirement system was too good
so they ended it and I was on the new
one which wasn't too good for me I took
a deferred retirement so I don't collect
my retirement because when I decided to
take that leap the leap of faith to give
up a paycheck every two weeks to Chase
my dream of being an entrepreneur I
didn't know if it was going to work so I
wanted to leave that door open so that
if I decided you know in the next five
years man I made a really big mistake I
want to go back that was that was the
decision the decision that I made so you
made the decision to become an
entrepreneur uh and you started an
awesome business that people can check
out I think the website is Uncle
louie.com no actually
um the website is americasfrontline.com
and the Uncle Louie Webb Uncle Louie
redirects that's what happened
yeah so and and that's kind of related
to what you mentioned about uh how I
started acting I when I was a kid I did
theater and I always loved acting and
music and
um I loved the show The Goldbergs
because it took place in the 80s which
is my favorite time 80s toys 80s music
to me that was a good decade I mean I'm
same same yeah so um the creator of the
show who it's based on Adam Goldberg had
reached out to me many times
and he was like hey do you know this
person can you help me um to bring this
80 star on the show and we did so much
together I feel like the 80s hookup I
was I was the 80s hookup I was the 80s
hookup and then eventually he's like you
know you really need to be on the show
and I was like I really want to be on
the show because it's my daughter's
favorite show and how cool would it be
we watch it together every week if I
don't tell her and one week we're
watching and I come on the show so it
evolved into that
um I did you know some episodes of that
show and it was an amazing experience
Adam became a friend
um and it wasn't until I actually went
to New York City I think in 2019 and I
sat down with Michael Strahan who's
become a Monumental figure in my life as
a mentor he's just taught me so much
he's a great guy super great guy and he
said to me you know everything you're
doing is so cool the UFC the WWE
um acting music uh Homeland Security but
have you ever thought that if you stop
doing all that and just focused on one
thing how great you might be
and that was a tough pill for me to
swallow because I really did I loved all
of those things but he was right and I
came home trying to wrap my head around
why I needed to focus on just one thing
and what would that one thing be right
would the one thing be wrestling WWE
because I was working with Bill Goldberg
at the time or would it be music is this
like some kind of like Goldberg mind
meld like everyone who's well you want
to know a funny Goldberg Side Story
um Goldberg called me one day Bill
Goldberg from WWE and he was very upset
I can't believe they made a TV show with
my name and I didn't approve this how
does this happen and I said well bill
there's other Goldbergs out there you
know and this one happens to be a really
nice guy who by the way grew up
idolizing you right because he was named
Adam Goldberg and he loved Bill Goldberg
and he's been trying to get your uh TV
agent to get you on the show but they
keep saying you won't do it I think it
would be a great idea for you to come on
the show and an opportunity for you to
show that you're a great comedic actor
oh I don't know I said well if I can get
you a deal if I can negotiate a deal
where you have multiple appearances in
our recurring co-star will you do it
yeah I'll do it but it's got to be it's
got to make sense so I went back to Adam
and we did it and Bill became the gym
teacher so we got Goldberg on the
Goldbergs and you know uh I think
shortly after that uh bill got cast for
NCIS and he's been doing a lot of TV so
everything tends to come together and
happen as it should but because of
Michael Strahan's advice I focus just on
uh my company which essentially creates
first responder-centric artwork and
turns it into Collectibles whether it's
coins pins patches I'm I'm wearing a new
pin that I made for you the unveiling of
it not left not right forward thank you
sir